the german company biointec partnered
with pfizer to develop and test a
coronavirus vaccine known as bnt
162 b2 a clinical trial demonstrated
that the vaccine has an efficacy rate of
95 percent in preventing covet 19.
the sar cov2 virus is studded with
proteins that it uses to enter human
cells
these so-called spiked proteins make a
tempting target for potential vaccines
and treatments
like the moderna vaccine the pfizer
bioentec vaccine
is based on the virus's genetic
instructions for building the spike
protein
the vaccine uses messenger rna genetic
material that our cells read to make
proteins
the molecule called mrna for short is
fragile
and would be chopped to pieces by our
natural enzymes if it were injected
directly into the body
to protect their vaccine pfizer and
bioentec wrap
mrna in oily bubbles made of lipid
nanoparticles
because of their fragility the mrna
molecules will quickly fall apart at
room temperature
pfizer is building special containers
with dry ice
thermal sensors and gps trackers to
ensure the vaccines can be transported
at -94 degrees fahrenheit to stay viable
after injection the vaccine particles
bump into cells infused to them
releasing mrna the cells molecules read
its sequence and build spike proteins
the mrna from the vaccine is eventually
destroyed by the cell
leaving no permanent trace some of the
spiked proteins form spikes that migrate
to the surface of the cell
and stick out their tips the vaccinated
cells also break up some of the proteins
into fragments which they present on
their surface
these protruding spikes in spiked
protein fragments can then be recognized
by the immune system
when a vaccinated cell dies the debris
will contain many spiked proteins and
protein fragments
which can then be taken up by a type of
immune cell called an antigen presenting
cell
the cell presents fragments of the spike
protein on its surface
when other cells called helper t cells
detect these fragments
the helper t cells can raise the alarm
and help marshal other immune cells to
fight the infection
other immune cells called b cells may
bump into the coronavirus spikes in
protein fragments on the surface of
vaccinated cells
a few of the b cells may be able to lock
onto the spiked proteins
if these b cells are then activated by
helper t cells
they will start to proliferate and pour
out antibodies that target the spike
protein
the antibodies can latch onto
coronavirus spikes mark the virus for
destruction
and prevent infection by blocking the
spikes from attaching to other cells
the antigen presenting cells can also
activate another type of immune cell
called a killer t cell to seek out and
destroy any coronavirus infected cells
that display the spike protein fragments
on their surfaces
the pfizer bio and tech vaccine requires
two injections
given 21 days apart to prime the immune
system well enough to fight off the
coronavirus
but because the vaccine is so new
researchers don't know how long its
protection might last
it's possible that in the months after
vaccination the number of antibodies in
killer t
cells will drop but the immune system
also contains special cells called
memory b
cells and memory t cells that might
retain information about the coronavirus
for years or even decades